[Music]
different cultures promote different
ideas about what counts as really high
level goods as what a society should
really strive for ganda people think of
good societies is one in which everybody
has lots of opportunities to take part
in relationships of hierarchical
interdependence between patrons and
clients that that feels like a good and
secure life there the robbing people in
Papua New Guinea define the good life as
one where in which people have as many
relationships with other people as they
can where both sides treat each other as
equals zero Americans Western culture
roughly speaking tend to value a world
in which individuals are free to become
who they choose to be unencumbered by
personal economic or political
relationships that would prevent them
from exercising this freedom these are
just three examples I could have given
you other examples of different versions
of the good but I really just want to
establish that if you look across
cultures you can see that people are
defining the good in different ways what
should these differences mean for our
moral lives what should these kind of
differences mean for the lives of people
who do learn about them and why should
you want to learn about them what's in
it for your own moral life for a good
part of the 20th century people would
link this kind of knowledge of cultural
differences to their own moral moral
lives by taking the position of
relativism okay they would say that a
good person is one who recognizes that
ideas and ways of behaving and notions
of morality are different across
cultures and a good person is one who
trains themselves to understand these
differences and therefore makes
themselves tolerant of them a good
person is the kind of person who could
look at the Jews on day saying that the
granary collapsed on the person
underneath it because the person
underneath it had been attacked by a
witch and could realize that that's a
perfectly reasonable way of thinking in
Sande in the Sande world and that it can
lead can give you a way of managing
death that's very productive in that
world and therefore you can be tolerant
of those different ideas that was this
notion of relativism that you learned
about other cultures so you could make
yourself I'm
or tolerable person okay of course as I
also mentioned relativism wasn't just
about saying other people's ideas make
sense in their own terms it also said
similar things about their moral
understandings it said you can't judge
other people's moral understandings and
judgments on the terms of your own
cultures moral ideas right so for
instance let's take a society in which
marriages link families and families are
the key building blocks of the political
world and therefore marriages are major
political events in societies that are
like that and there are many of them
around the world marriages tend to be
arranged by adults not by the younger
people getting married and that's
thought to be morally appropriate indeed
it's thought to be morally wrong and
selfish for young people to marry on the
basis of their own feelings as a
marriage is so important the political
structure it has to be managed by the
parental generation that's morally right
it would be immoral for people just to
act on their own feelings which can be
passing after all as we know by the
divorce rate okay the argument from a
relatives would argue that only when you
judge arranged marriages from the point
of view of a culture that puts
individuals and their free choices first
the only if you judge arranged marriages
from the point of view of a culture
where the highest good as individuals
getting to make their own choices for
themselves would you judge arranged
marriages in that other culture as
morally bad in fact you might call them
as they're often called in England
forced marriages right a relativist
would say morally you shouldn't do that
you are judging them from the point of
view of your own cultural understandings
you should take the time to learn why
they make sense for the people who do
them okay on the basis of arguments like
that moral relativists promoted the idea
that tolerance was a key virtue you
might want to study anthropology you
might want to learn about other cultures
so that you could become a more tolerant
person that would be a good moral
project that is a good moral project
fewer and fewer people these days are
attracted to this kind of full-blown
real
there's been a kind of hardening of
moral attitudes at least at their edges
you know at least when it comes to
looking at people from other cultures
more and more these days people even
educated people even some
anthropologists want to be able to
identify and condemn practices they
think are evil even if they have to make
those judgments that have practices bad
across cultural boundaries boundaries
more and more people want to be able to
morally judge people living in societies
other than their own they're not willing
to make the relativist well there's a
philosopher named Gen John Cook who said
that one of the things about moral
relativism was it forced you into
position of what he called moral recusal
I can't judge them i recused myself
because it's not my culture fewer and
fewer people are willing to accept the
demand for moral refusal that comes with
being a relativist so the question I
want to focus on answering the rest of
my talk today is this ok given that many
people these days don't want to be
relativists anymore they want to be able
to judge across cultures they want to be
able to say that some things are evil
and should be stopped even if it's
across a cultural boundary given that
people don't want to be relativist what
work is left for knowledge of cultural
differences to do in our own moral lives
is there a way we can make use of moral
differences not just to become tolerant
of everything but to improve ourself
morally in some other way so that's the
question I want to answer if we don't
want to be relativists for the sake of
argument a lot of people don't want to
be so let's say for the sake of argument
we don't want to just tolerate
everything what worked in moral
differences do for our own moral
development and I think that's good for
anthropology too because I should say
with the decline of relativism and
anthropology has become a little less
popular so I for what it's worth I think
it's a key project for anthropology now
to to find new moral uses for cultural
difference and that's what I'm I'm
trying to do ok in working ok so what I
want to argue is that and I'm going to
be abstract for a minute but this will
get concrete very quickly is that even
if a broad-based cultural relativism
doesn't work for people anymore it
doesn't give moral difference or role to
play in our lives anymore that people
are attracted to I still think that the
study of the various ways cultures
define the good can help us find a role
for cross-cultural differences in our
moral life okay even if we don't want to
be full-blown relatives and say we're
just going to tolerate anything that
makes sense to other people I think that
studying the ways people define the good
still can help us develop our own moral
understandings and in in working to
substantiate that point I'm gonna
suggest two different ways that a focus
on different notions of the good is not
the same thing that's relativism okay
I'm gonna try to convince you that
looking at the kind of differences I
looked at in the first half between
different versions of the good isn't
quite the same thing as what relativists
used to be up to and that it's for this
reason I think that focusing on
differences in croix in definitions to
the good across cultures can help us
think about how cultural differences can
matter for our own lives so first I want
to note a crucial way in which a focus
on cultural understandings are the goods
leads us to dwell on very different
kinds of differences than the relativist
dealt with that's my first thing we
could call that an empirical point I'm
gonna say that the differences that we
focus on the differences that are out
there in the world that we choose to
focus on are gonna be different if we
see ourselves as doing a comparative
study of the good across cultures as
opposed to doing a relativist study just
of cultural difference in general so
that's the first point we're gonna look
at different things but then I also want
to draw on a philosophical position
known as value pluralism to suggest why
a focus on the good can can allow for a
different use of data on moral
difference than relativism did so first
I want to talk about the the kinds of
differences in the world we're going to
attend to if we focus on different
definitions a good then I'm gonna make a
philosophical argument in conclusion
about why focusing on differences in the
good is a different project than trying
to become a tolerant relativist so first
onto my point about the fact that this
cross-cultural study of differences in
the good is a little different than
relatives if you think about it and
probably some of you have done this
yourself when when anthropologists or
philosophers or people in their own
everyday conversations want to make
relativist arguments what do they focus
on in other cultures well they tend to
focus on things they find morally
upsetting they tend to focus on things
they find pretty
repugnant when you're about to have or
you know somebody's gonna make a
relativist argument when they say to you
something like well I bet you think
arranged marriage is bad or I bet you
think ritual genital modification is bad
or I bet you think infanticide is bad or
there's a wonderful anthropological
article a few years ago that actually
started with the sentence I bet you
think child labor is bad I knew I was in
for a good article when she started with
but relatives always want to start you
with something that you find morally
repugnant but something you basically
find as it were disgusting and then
their technique is to tell you enough
about the culture it comes from that
maybe you could appreciate why it makes
moral sense in its own local cultural
parents for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you